realice una secuencia de
transformaciones para llevar el peligo
no móvil al público no móvil a este azul
de aquí en el polígono fijo p q r s ok
entonces quiero llevar este polígono
azul en este polígono en este polígono
gris así que comencemos porque no con
una traslación y nos piden especificar
como quiero trasladar porque vector así
que veamos si pienso en cómo se mueven
los puntos de este polígono azul parece
que este punto azul de aquí corresponde
al punto q así que primero me voy a
mover cuántas unidades por el sobre el
eje x me voy a mover 7 unidades sobre el
eje x 7 unidades y luego tengo que subir
cuántas de menos 5 a 4 así que 9
unidades
ok entonces vamos progresando ahora
tengo el polígono así
este quizás podría simplemente
reflejarlo a través de esta línea pero
vamos a explorar dando un poco vamos a
ver qué pasa si lo traslado lo roto
perdón si lo roto
alrededor de este punto parece que 180
grados así que vamos a rotarlo alrededor
del punto 44 4,4 por ciento ochenta
grados ok
llegó a esta situación ahora que tengo
que hacer pues podría rotarlo más mal
creo que solo lo tengo que reflejar a
través de esta línea de la línea que es
igual a cuatro así que agreguemos una
reflexión una reflexión sobre la línea
que va de
de donde pues quiero las líneas de igual
a 4 así que
42 y ahí está ahí ya tenemos el polígono
estamos en lo correcto